we've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen
afghans fall
four days ago five days ago
what
what if it was a year ago would that
make it four or five days ago an
astonishing election by the president of
the united states
the good news is that we have president
empathy out there the most empathetic
president of all time right super
grandpa empathy
he's out there just to show how much he
cares what an empathetic guy now quick
reminder
he's not empathetic he has never been
empathetic
back in 2010 he was asked by richard
holbrook then the special envoy by the
obama administration to afghanistan and
pakistan about a hasty withdrawal from
afghanistan and what that would mean for
the people of afghanistan and the people
who had allied themselves with us
sacrificed their lives sacrificed
themselves on behalf of yes an american
mission in afghanistan
and his explicit response according to
richard holbrook's diary this is joe
biden was quote f that nixon and
kissinger got away with it in vietnam
okay and uh and joe biden's main message
here is no regards
this is an astonishing clip so he was uh
he was interviewed by george
stephanopoulos and when a democratic
president is interviewed by george
stephanopoulos usually it is a human
centipede performance because that's
george stephanopoulos job george
stephanopoulos was the press secretary
for hillary clinton back during the
1990s he is a democrat democratic
apparatchik who somehow ended up as one
of the chief anchors at abc news which
is wild right imagine if karl rove were
one of the chief anchors for fox news
he'd be very strange
not like an opinion host the chief
actual news anchor so normally when
george stephanopoulos is um is
doing an interview with the democratic
politician it looks more like soft core
pornography than it does like an actual
interview but george stephanopoulos
could not save biden from himself here
he just could not
so he asks him a pretty simple question
he asked him it's chaos at the airport
right we're watching people fall from
planes joe biden's answer here is one of
the most atrocious answers i've ever
heard from an american president on any
topic and go back and listen i was
highly critical of many of the things
that trump said in interviews i was
certainly critical of the stuff that
obama said in interviews on a regular
basis
this is i think the worst thing i've
ever heard an american president say in
an interview and that encompasses a lot
of bad things being said in interviews
here is george stephanopoulos with the
presidents of the united states god help
us joe biden
we've seen those hundreds of people
packed into a c-17 we've seen
afghans fall
four days ago five days ago what did you
think when you first saw those pictures
well i thought was weird we have to gain
control of this we have to move this
more quickly
we have to move in a way in which we can
take control that airport
and we did
so you don't think this could have been
handled the sex it could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no
no no mistakes it's been error-free it's
a perfect it's a perfect operation a
perfect operation where afghans are
clinging to the wheel wells of planes
escaping afghanistan and then falling
from 4 000 feet to their death on the
tarmac
perfect perfect operation more than that
i gotta say when stephanopoulos asks him
about
what just happened there he says it was
four or five days ago
so
number one i was unaware that if a man
falls 4 000 feet from the wheel well of
a c-17 to the tarmac that he remains
alive four or five days later that he
actually dies and then four or five days
pass and then he's okay again it was
four or five days ago that is the
response of this petulant man-child
president this adult
this adult president his response is it
was four or five days ago
what
what if it was a year ago would that
make it
four or five days ago
how in the world is that supposed to
make any difference at all by the way it
wasn't it was two days ago when he gave
this interview
i understand that every time joe biden
takes a mid-morning nap and wakes up he
thinks it's a new day but it absolutely
is not
okay this is this is just
an astonishing dear election by the
president of the united states and for
captain empathy over here to be saying
oh it was four or five days ago and
could you have handled anything better
here no nothing could have been handled
better nothing
truly nothing there are seven people who
are trampled to death at this airport
we have women throwing babies over the
razor wire at this airport we still have
10 to 15 000 americans american citizens
who are stuck in kabul
right now
as we speak
we have another somewhere between 60 and
100 000
afghan allies people who worked with our
military interpreters
members of the special operations forces
in afghanistan
for whom american soldiers have signed
affidavits by basically saying that
these are people who we ought to save
these are random syrian citizens who are
just being put upon by the government
and we don't have any background
information on them these are people who
actively worked with the united states
government with our military with our
military contractors
they're stuck over there and joe biden
can't explain
how he could have done this any better
hey then joe biden goes even further
right he says well there was no way no
way that we could have gotten out
without chaos this was inevitable this
was the inevitable ending to this saga
inevitable
we were holding
our bases in afghanistan with a skeleton
crew of somewhere between 2 500 and 3
500 people
if you look at the number of troops
united states troops on the ground in
afghanistan year on year it has declined
essentially every year since 2014.
we went from having tens of thousands of
troops as in like 30 40 50 to 100 000
troops
in the in the 2010 2011 2012 period all
the way down to about 10 000 troops in
the posted 2014 period and then all the
way down to 2 500 troops officially in
afghanistan as of january of this year
and joe biden decided that we had to
precipitously pull out so he could get a
headline about how he'd ended the
quote-unquote endless war
the thing that's so amazing about that
by the way is that when you look at
where american troops are stationed all
over the world
afghanistan barely ranks in like the top
by the time that we left
afghanistan had 25 3 500 troops there we
have over 5 000 troops in qatar we have
5 000 troops in kuwait
we have 26 000 troops in korea we have
something like 12 000 troops in italy
we have 40 000 troops still in japan we
have 33 000 troops in germany
this is not a quote-unquote endless war
for the united states there is no
necessity for this quote-unquote
precipitous pull-out and when he says
there's no way to get out without chaos
no there absolutely was
here is joe biden saying this it's
insane
the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
unbelievable by the way quick note here
if he thought it was inevitable that
this chaos was going to happen
then why was he taking a vacation
really
why
by the way a bit of a conflicting
message there we were told by his
military was totally unexpected a month
ago he was saying that the taliban would
not be able to take hubble so either he
was lying then or he's lying now
those are the only two choices
or he's lying both times it is quite
possible that he was informed by his
intelligence community that this was a
significant possibility he lied about it
a month ago then it happened and then he
said oh yeah it was totally foreseeable
so he's lying both times that's
the most probable situation
i mean remember he says there was no way
to get us out without chaos just a month
ago he was joe biden saying the same
gonna be saigon
do you see any parallels between this
withdrawal and what happened in vietnam
with some people feeling whatsoever
zero what you had is you had entire
brigades breaking through the gates of
our embassy
six if i'm not mistaken
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army
they're not they're not remotely
comparable in terms of capability
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of a embassy in the of the
united states from afghanistan it is not
at all comfortable
that was july 8th
july 8th
unbelievable
un
freaking believable by the way joe biden
also told george stephanopoulos that uh
the taliban have changed said what i
think they're going through a sort of
existential crisis about what they want
to be do what they
about do they want to be recognized by
the international community as being a
legitimate government yeah that's that's
exactly right probably they're going
through an existential crisis
well done sir he's a delusion delusional
fully delusional
and by the way biden is now saying he is
grateful to the taliban he says i'm not
sure i would have predicted george nor
would you or anyone else than when we
decided to leave that they'd provide
safe passage for americans to get out
are we sure they've provided safe
passage for americans to get out at this
point
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content